In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 16th, on which we commemorate our Holy Father
Tekon, Bishop of Amethyst in Cyprus.
On the 16th of the month, we celebrate the memory of our Holy Father Tekon, the Wonder
Worker, Bishop of Amethyst on Cyprus.
Our Holy Father Tekon was the Son of simple Christian parents from Amethyst, a town in
southern Cyprus.
Consecrated to God from childhood, he grew up in a devout environment and was ordained
reader.
His father, who was a baker, told him one day to go to the town to sell his loaves, but acting
according to evangelical precepts, Tekon gave the loaves away to the poor.
When his father learned of this, he was violently angry.
The child responded by saying to him that he had only lent the loaves to the poor, and
that they would receive a hundredfold in recompense, as promised by the Lord.
In fact, when they returned to the house, they found their storerooms full of wheat.
After the death of his father, Tekon gave away all his possessions, and rejecting worldly
concerns in order to bear the light and easy yoke of Christ.
He presented himself to Bishop Nimonius, who, recognizing the young man's qualities
ordained him deacon, and charged him with the tasks of administering the church's goods,
and teaching the people.
Through his words, full of fire, of divine love, Tekon easily refuted the deceit of both
Jews and pagans, and presented a great number of both to the Bishop for baptism.
On the death of Nimonius, St. Tekon was consecrated, Bishop of Amethas, by St. Epiphanios,
and from that time, shown forth as a lamp of the candelabrum of the church, convincing some
of the truth of the gospel by his irrefutable arguments and leading others to the faith
by his striking miracles.
He would cast out demons, heal those sick in body and spirit, and, in brief, make the impossible
possible through the grace of God acting in him.
When certain idolaters persisted in the worship of false gods, the Holy Bishop entered their
temple and cast down their statues.
Holding a whip in his hand, he cast out Anthusa, the priestess of Artemis, who had heaped
curses upon him.
Afterwards, she realized that the power of God was with the saint, confessed Christ and
was baptized, taking the name of Anthea.
One day, in a great concourse of dancing and obscenities, the pagans organized a procession
with the statue of the goddess of Cyprus.
When they were passing the church, St. Tikhon came out of the building and destroyed the
statue, confounding their superstitions to such a degree that all the pagans present were
converted and asked to be baptized.
On another occasion, the Holy Bishop was accused by two pagans, Calikios and Cleopatra, and
was forced to appear before the island's governor.
He replied to the magistrate that, as he was a servant of God, the friend of humankind,
he could not but imitate him and have pity on all those who were benited in the darkness
of error, by teaching them that there is only one true God.
He added that he thought of the pagans as sick people whom God had charged him to heal, and
that he was ready to suffer their curses and ill-treatment as a small token of response
to the sufferings endured by the Lord for our salvation.
Impressed by the saint's tranquil confidence, the judge had him released, and this audience
brought about numerous conversions among those who had been present.
Ticon possessed a field in which he had a vine planted.
One day, sometime before his departure from this earthly life, he visited it again to observe
the work of the vine-growers who were cutting off dead shoots.
He took up one of the discarded shoots and presented it to Christ, asking him to restore life to
it and to make it bring forth sweet and abundant fruit before its season. He then planted the shoot
in the earth and assured those who were present that the miracle would continue to happen forever
as a witness to the invisible presence of their shepherd and his vigilant prayers.
In fact, every year after the saint's death, the grapes were found still to be green on the eve
of the 16th of June. The day the saint's memory was celebrated, as was natural in that season,
but they would ripen suddenly during the vigil and always be black and juicy by the time of the divine
liturgy so that they were able to be used in the holy sacrifice. Some of the grapes were taken home
by the faithful to bless their own vines, and others were used to heal the sick.
When St. Tekon learned from God of his impending death, he went to pay a visit to the villagers who
were in the fields for the barley harvest. The people ran to receive his blessing and heard a heavenly
voice calling the saint to the heavenly kingdom. Three days later, he fell ill. He who had for long
years revived by his prayer all who were sick. He consoled his mother who was weeping at the bedside,
reminding her that we must live on earth in the hope of the resurrection. He then gathered together
his spiritual children, both clergy and layfolk, and spoke highly of the dignity of Christians who have
become children of God and brothers and sisters of Christ, called to follow in his footsteps without
letting themselves be deceived by the seductions of this life. After remaining confined to his bed
for three days, the holy pastor was joyfully received in the celestial court, while the whole island
of Cyprus was in mourning during his funeral celebrated by all the bishops and priests of the island
in the presence of an immense crowd, the saint's body shone forth with radiant light and gave forth a
fragrant perfume. In conformity with his promise, St. Tekon did not cease to watch over his flock.
He healed a woman of leprosy and delivered a deaf and dumb child possessed by the demon.
This happened in the following manner. As the parents of the child sadly left the saint's shrine
after having prayed at length for their child's healing and attributing the failure of their request
to their own sins, St. Tekon appeared to them as a priest and exhorted them to persevere.
The demon then agitated the child terribly and finally fled away, crying out,
O Tekon, it is your confidence before God that has driven me out.
The child then began to speak normally. Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord,
Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us and save us.